young sheldon facing a new challenge in
tonight's season 4 premiere
after graduating high school he's got a
breakdown when he realizes he may not be
ready for college
when you're afraid of something if it's
necessary you have to be scared but do
it anyway that's what bravery is
and there's even more drama as dale
tries to make amends with
meemaw you can catch the season premiere
of young sheldon tonight right here on
channel 8.
meemaw that's a fun name also tonight
the debut of the new chuck war comedy be
positive following
drew a therapist and divorced father as
he finds a kidney donor when he runs
into gina a woman from his past
the two form an unlikely friendship
yes they are stars be positive heirs
right after
young sheldon
that was the weirdest that was the
weirdest comment she just said about the
actors
yes they are stars
that was so unique oh boy here are the
actors in this show
you should know they are stars we can
confirm
that they are stars
hey ted all right i wanted to add i
wanted to add that one of the good shows
on cbs it's star wars they brought yeah
yeah hey buddy
star trek stars in that show too star
star trek
we can confirm that they're stars all
right